Ezra Bridger has finally made his
long-awaited return to the Star Wars
franchise but did you recognize the
actor who plays him Star Wars fans had a
lot to get excited about going into the
Disney plus series Ahsoka Not only was
the sokotano about to get a live-action
project of her own after over a decade
in animation but the series was to Mark
the live-action debut of beloved Rebels
characters as the series unfolded the
likes of Harris and Doula and Sabine
Wren took the spotlight while it's been
great to see these animated favorites in
live action fans have continued to ask
the big question where is Ezra Bridger
Ezra last appeared in the rebels finale
in which Upon A per Guild take him and
Grand Admiral thrawn out of the known
Galaxy leaving Sabine and the rest of
his friends behind years after his
disappearance Sabine travels to a
distant world in the hopes of finding
him and sure enough Ezra is alive and
well
can't wait to go home for Ahsoka actor
imanis fondi takes over from Rebels
voice actor Taylor Gray it's entirely
possible that you've seen this fondy
before though it's not all that likely
this is because with Ahsoka he is adding
a major credit to his rather short
filmography unlike many of the actors on
Ahsoka who boast robust acting resumes
that go back decades and spans screens
big and small imanisfandi is only just
starting out in the industry his
earliest credit is from 2017 in the form
of the short film Fu Glory Days in which
he takes on the role of hammer this
filmography is largely populated by more
short films from subsequent years such
as 2018's why we fight and 2019's I am
McKenzie elois fondi does have some
feature-length efforts to his name as
well as fandi scored his first feature
film Credit in 2018's red 11 which was
directed by none other than Robert
Rodriguez who also directed episodes of
the Mandalorian and book of Boba Fett
asfandi later took roles in Pedra Austin
weird and the Will Smith LED King
Richard right now the most recent Silver
Screen production under respondi's belt
was 2022's the inspection though it
stands the reason that his body of work
acting talent and exposure from Ahsoka
will bring him more roles in the near
future notably asfandi has done a superb
job building very big shoes and under
difficult circumstances if there's one
thing the Star Wars fandom has become
known for over the years it's a
reluctance and occasional hostility
toward change
you seriously think wow you're about as
bright as a binary Droid they're not
gonna come for me people don't do that
so when the news broke that amanas fandi
was on the hook to take the Baton from
Taylor Gray as Ezra Bridger some online
fans naturally pushed back of course
while fans in certain corners of the
internet voice their displeasure at this
new casting most folks were excited to
see where his fandy's take on the
character was headed in fact before the
series even released fans expressed a
great deal of support for his casting
back in December 2022 a redditor posted
an interview with his fondy in which he
had been asked about his casting as Ezra
on Ahsoka in the comment section Star
Wars fans were blown away by how
perfectly cast he was with his voice
standing out as a solid match for an
aged up version of the character that's
the idea in another thread fans were
Amazed by how much as fondy looks like
the animated version of Ezra and
discussed how they couldn't wait to see
him suit up on the small screen so far
both as fondy and the live-action
version of Ezra appear to be a hit and
will no doubt see more of this version
of the character as ahsoka's first
season draws to a close